hello everyone welcome to
congratulations episode 166 that's right
yep that's right
it's episode 166 and we're finally here
at 166 always wondered when we do but
back back we'll be up to 166 dude you
know what I'm thinking right now which
is the best part of this whole thing for
me is remember a few episodes ago I
thought the left input of my year was
not able to hear stuff and then one fire
said to me no you have a hearing problem
on live while we were doing the [ __ ]
podcast and I go like this well that's
interesting because I was offended and
then I and then I decided you know what
maybe I do have an ear problem but what
I didn't do was and this is just for the
[ __ ] real [ __ ] that are true
to this podcast I [ __ ] go like this
with the headphones and I just switched
them like this and now I can't hear out
of my right ear so [ __ ] we did
deductive we use deductive reasoning
dude and guess what it's not my ears
it's definitely the [ __ ] headphones
and I knew it all along and I did the
thing where I was like you know what
maybe I'm you know I second-guess on
myself but all along dude I was [ __ ]
right man I was and that and that is
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] amazing dude that
makes me feel so good because I actually
thought I was deaf for a little bit and
I thought I needed to go to the [ __ ]
doctor and get my ears squeegeed out
again or whatever the [ __ ] they call it
dude he put he put a water in my ear
saline or whatever in my ear and we held
it there for a while and then I dumped
it out it looked like someone took a
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] ball anyway so it's
one of what episode 166 and we're here
and you know what I'm tired dude and
this is the second week of the [ __ ]
quarantine third week of the quarantine
whatever
nobody's here I'm here solo I'm doing it
responsible people who have podcast man
unless you've got a big [ __ ] table
and I'm
talk about a big table like Bruce Wayne
style [ __ ] don't be [ __ ] having guests
don't be sitting on a couch with another
guest and sharing a microphone don't do
that [ __ ] just kick it this is why your
boy had a solo podcast just a case
Armageddon was coming and Armageddon was
coming out all you know and Armageddon
came and I've watched Armageddon the
other day by the way and it's cool I
remember when I first saw Armageddon I
wasn't sure about Ben Affleck about how
if he was handsome or not and then I
went back and I saw him again like two
days ago and I saw him and I was like oh
he was [ __ ] handsome as all get-out
and dude I don't think I was being a
hater to be brutally honest with you
guys I don't think I was being a hater
he was a little bit older these a little
bit older than me but her mother girls
in my high school were like Oh Ben
Affleck is so hot and I'm like yeah he's
okay you know it's kind of regular
looking but I don't think I was being a
hater I think I just [ __ ] my tastes
you know my tastes just [ __ ] kind of
got better as I got older within guys
it's episode 166 now I want to go I want
to start out by saying dude we got two
more weeks left until my Netflix special
comes out so get that in your queue it's
coming up April 14th it's called no pain
crystally is comedy special hour and you
got it you got a you got to get that on
it's good or yo y'all done watching all
the other [ __ ] you've been watching you
done watch a crusher especially you're
done watching Tom Segura special you
done watching Tiger King you're done
watching all those things because no
pains come in April 14th and I'm really
excited man I know I said it before but
it's definitely definitely my best
special or taping anything that I've
done and I'm really happy about it and
I'm so excited that it is the most
recent one that's going to be out
because who knows when I'll [ __ ] do
another one because of this coronavirus
just got nervous because I said
coronavirus because I thought maybe in
my head I was like because here's the
deal when I do the ads I'm not supposed
to say coronavirus and I said
coronavirus right now and my heart
skipped a beat because I thought maybe
it was an addy yes it's okay though dude
it's okay cuz it's just my podcast one
fire and I even get rid of our operating
remotely dude
not even close to me so I could say
whatever I want this time I mean I say
what I want no matter what but this time
even more so I'm rolling on my dole oh
dude what does it mean I don't know
rule number two Park said but yeah so my
Netflix special is coming out I'm
excited about it the trailer drops
really soon you guys are [ __ ] gonna
give a day here see that and all that on
[ __ ] Netflix is a joke comedy and all
that stuff I got my iced americano are
you guys staying inside dude stay the
[ __ ] inside for real I'm getting pissed
the [ __ ] off when I see people at the
beach I'm getting pissed the [ __ ] off
when I see people at farmers market
market I'm getting pissed the [ __ ] off
when I see more than four people
together man I'm getting pissed off when
I see three people together man just
stay in your [ __ ] house it's annoying
as [ __ ] that I'm doing my part bro I
went to get a a coffee because I wanted
a coffee I went in boom and I came out
that [ __ ] was like Ethan Hunt and
mission impossible I just [ __ ] it was
like when he [ __ ] and catches himself
right before the [ __ ] when he does
this [ __ ] right before he hits the
ground and then catches his sweat
because if the heat rises too much I
guess what my babies he gets caught dude
when he caught his sweat I was [ __ ]
17 when he caught his sweat I go alright
Ethan hunts that dope
any-any and so that was how I am when I
go to the [ __ ] coffee bean I go in
and I got my mask on dude and they say
don't wear a mask if you're not infected
but they also say act like you have it
so which one is it dude I mean they're
acting like I'm having it or I don't
have it or what's the deal don't wear a
mask only wear a mask if you have it
they say only only time a mask helps is
if you have it and then they say if
you're going anywhere or they say so
don't wear a mask only only wear a mask
if you have it cuz that's when it helps
it doesn't help when you don't wear it
when you when you wear a mask you don't
have it so don't not have it and wear a
mask
and then they say to be safe I quit you
have it okay
mask on dude mask on so I wear the mask
I don't have gloves my buddy Craig has
gloves I'm jealous and I go in and I
don't touch anything bro I don't touch
anything I stay six to ten feet away
from people when the guy walks by me and
there's a small opening I go like this
I'm like a ninja pace I'll paste it up
against the wall I'll paste it up
against the wall and and I was at the
Chi and I don't want to be I don't want
to be a dick you know I don't want to be
shitty and stuff like that because when
I went to get the coffee because I
needed a coffee because I needed to
[ __ ] be alive I thought it was gonna
do my podcast and I didn't because I
didn't forgot to recharge the battery on
the [ __ ] camera but this is how it
goes when you're rolling on your dolo
and and so I went to go get it and I was
there and everything was moving really
[ __ ] smooth and the girl was making
the coffee before and I thought she was
making my coffee and she had her hand
all up in the thing just doing the thing
and I was like dude what is this [ __ ]
girl doing is she joking and I was like
I'm gonna ask her for another one and
then she put it on the thing and another
guy took it and I was like this - it's
playing Russian roulette with this
lady's hands and then she made my coffee
and the other girl made my coffee and
didn't even barely touch it and I was
just like rolling on my doll oh and I
took the [ __ ] coffee and I took a
straw she was like would you like a
straw and I go like this
I'll get it and I got it and I unwrapped
it without even touching it popped it in
the thing got the disinfectant wipes
stroked off my cup like that with
disinfectant wipes you know I did it
like this I stroked it off and then I
started sucking on it
I was stroking it off with it
disinfectant wipes I took the
disinfectant wipes and I was stroking it
off on the coffee and then I started
sucking the strong when you're drinking
iced coffee in an Americano and the
coronavirus is round it's like you're
sucking [ __ ] and you could [ __ ] put
that in my goddamn tombstone because
you're doing the twisty hand thing by
the way girls do the twisty hand thing
anyway we're not talking about that this
is about the coronavirus but my point is
when I am outside I'm
manolo and I'm [ __ ] and so and then
when I got my my thing a [ __ ]
homeless guy came in and I don't like to
play I don't like to be like that and
I'm like to make fun of the homeless I
understand that it's a real [ __ ] talk
about an epidemic you know and it sucks
that he came in and in my head out out
my face was cool dude my face was just
regular cool like I had my poker face
going on
just chill but in my head I go like am I
the real me goes like this Oh for [ __ ]
sake we're all getting it do you know
what I mean the guy comes in with the
long beard holding seven blankets and I
and I go like this oh okay well for
[ __ ] sake we're all getting in my face
is cool but face looks like I'm ready
for war but in a relaxed state you know
like I'm ready for war and you know what
my face looks like we're ready for war
and the sides are equal do you
understand and we're like okay well
we'll see how this goes but and the
inside I go like this well we're ready
for war but really we have 20 percent of
what the other army has and I go like
this okay well we're all gonna get it
and then I felt bad that I felt like he
was gonna and then I had to leave and he
was like in the doorway a little bit and
I was like trying to eke out sucking
sucking [ __ ] amount americano it was
just all [ __ ] up and then I stood
outside and there was a Persian guy with
his doors open of his Range Rover and it
was playing this music that was so
Persian and just I don't even know if he
was Persian or not whatever the language
was that the music was playing it was so
awful and also so loud like don't oh
thank you I should have walked out said
thank you for the music dude thank you
very much
they all had masks on and [ __ ] gloves
on there were three of them anyway and
said then some guy came out thought it
was funny and was like hey you want a
mask okay you want to buy a mask for $14
and I was like I don't do these jokes ro
anyway I don't think I have the [ __ ]
coronavirus
it's real out there though man it's just
[ __ ]
everyone's getting it Chris Cuomo got it
my buddy Michael yo got it that's just
brutal that dude saw the devil it looked
like he put up an Instagram that was
just made me [ __ ] sad dude like let
me see if I can put it up but he he he
got the coronavirus and okay the page
isn't available even though it is
available and I know it is because I
follow anime yes dude I'll put it on my
phone but man he just [ __ ] here
listen to this first say thank you for
all the thoughts and prayers sweetest
guy I know home now people ask me what
happened so basically I went to the
hospital I had pneumonia and Koroma that
same time it really did the [ __ ]
one-two really slapped it I would have
said to run it first just to get out the
way but this dude had a one-two combo
right there yeah doctor said this is
gonna go good fast so just gonna go
really bad fast and you know they let
you know right away when you check in
you're not gonna see your family that's
[ __ ] up what happens you're not seeing
your family because they'll have enough
equipment and you're just too contagious
um so you know it was a rough couple
nights but uh made it through I
appreciate all the to love the prayers
man meant a lot
to all the people that uh you know while
I'm in the hospital getting better I was
looking at the ring cam and I saw a
bunch of friends drop off stuff at the
house for my family that meant so much
so I meant so much to all my comedian
friends for reaching out
send me Carano jokes I did do that I
loved it
was so funny I spit up blood you know we
got to keep laughing I'm gonna help I
guess we gotta keep laughing so that's
true I do believe that I made it through
so far it's all good but uh just want
you to know the people that are dying in
the hospital man
I don't care what you're reading I was
in there around people like that and I
died alone they don't have family in
there man
they can't and you hear stories where
nurses are surrounded and the nurses and
the first responders man you guys are
amazing risking your life for us you
know but I rebelled the stories I'm
seeing all these stories of people dying
and I know when I was in there they were
like yo it goes bad you're not gonna see
anybody you know so just remember those
people you know I made it you know but
we need a shifted attention to the
people death need to help him please
stay safe show him some love on his uh
on his Instagram or something I'm I
think I'll probably make him feel better
dude the guy family
I have a question for you and I was done
there was this so we have a lot of very
angry media all around this room and
they want one of these seats but because
of social distancing we are keeping them
empty and they are keeping them empty
will there ever be a time when all of
those really angry angry people who
don't like me much to start off with but
now they really don't like - were there
ever be a time when these seats are full
like full to the brim like it used to be
with people are almost sitting on each
other's lap and this whole row over here
is packed and now they're outside
wanting to get in and they're very
jealous of all of these reporters mr.
Gargan or is that something like that
people are just dying you know and this
guy's making it about him and they're
all very jealous cuz they can't come
into my thing member when he was talking
about ratings hey my [ __ ] thing is so
rated so highly my press conferences are
really rated so highly like we're tuning
in [ __ ] we're tuning in because it's
the coronavirus by the way this guy is
actively using this to [ __ ] campaign
on his next year
he's got TV coverage every day about
this Korona [ __ ] and he's just using it
to [ __ ] try and get elected next year
again that's [ __ ] crazy dude but at
least they're secure there's a cure did
you know that there's a cure for the
corona virus it's these two [ __ ]
[ __ ] how [ __ ] boring is this guy
at Thanksgiving the other guy dude the
other guy is like waiting to talk and
he's just going like this doing nothing
he looks like he's trying to [ __ ]
guess what floor is on in the elevator
so insecure the guy on the right
doesn't know what he's gonna say that
doesn't know what he's gonna say next
flying time Oh coming busted you will
destroy through covet 19 no more no more
Oh
his hype man dude no more this guy's
like [ __ ] uh what's his name the
United States of America is so there's a
cure again
good this [ __ ] [ __ ] has a cure
dude the other guy is just like [ __ ]
the other guy what's his name uh was
that guy who sings who's that guy guys I
don't need no [ __ ] hook on this beat
and that's the hook what's that song I
is Nelly what was this [ __ ] Nellie's
goddammit Nellie's a sidekick a hype man
god damn it really ruin in the [ __ ]
joke what's his name I don't need no
[ __ ] hook on this beat Saint lunatic
the st. lunatics who who were the st.
lunatics goddamn I'm ruining this so far
but so hard but I don't care Natalie st.
lunatics who are the same god damn it
st. lunatics you know how stupid is that
[ __ ] name I don't need no [ __ ]
hook on this beat you guys some of you
guys know who it is and I'm getting
pissed off some with an M I don't need
no hook on the
Pete who is it please here we go Murphy
Lee Murphy Lee did I think eyes Murphy
Lee the guy in the [ __ ] other way
there's Nellie and Murphy Lee the
religious version you would destroy
through covet 90 no more he just goes
you'll destroy through covin 19 and the
guy Murphy League religious Murphy Lee
goes in covent 19 and he says no more in
just no more
I say insecure dude I don't need no
[ __ ] hook on this beat remember that
song yo check it out this [ __ ] baby
nelly broadcasting live from WMT radio
yeah we got a special event for y'all
tonight y'all about to see something so
- doesn't he remember this song dude
people in st. Louis would just [ __ ] of
course it's not playing no cool yeah all
right
well I don't know why it's not playing
now but it's not playing so no more no
more wow dude here's this is the thing
that like when they say like old white
men they're a problem and then I want to
be like I shut the [ __ ] up dude
everyone's a problem everyone's a
problem if you put anybody in power
they're the problem cuz they're gonna
abuse it what's that whole thing [ __ ]
power destroys but absolute power
destroys absolutely or whatever it is
butchered it so hard oh well you know
what I'm talking about my point is I
want to be on white guy's sides because
I'm a white guy and then these [ __ ]
guys come up and they're just like these
pastors are so funny they're so
passionate about [ __ ] absolutely
nothing they're passionate about
something that straight-up doesn't work
well like what is everybody gonna say
now well okay but that people still die
the Chris Cuomo got it [ __ ] Chris Cuomo
is a religious [ __ ] these guys on
marched bucking 29th no more Kove it no
more when God stands on your head and
then Chris Cuomo [ __ ]
March 31st got it coronavirus no more
March 29th March 31st Chris Cuomo hey
got coronavirus coronavirus goes like
this to Chris Cuomo let's get after it
when Chris Cuomo starts his [ __ ] dude
Chris Cuomo is so aggressive he starts
his [ __ ] show so aggressive he's
those let's get after it like dude it's
a [ __ ] news show you know that's
hilarious let's get after it so anyway
this happened that's what he does dude
let's get after it so anyway these are
the things that happened that's
hilarious y'all [ __ ] ready to talk
about what just happened let's [ __ ]
do this
this happened five minutes ago I'm Chris
Cuomo let's get after it
the president said something he's jacked
dude let me tell you something Chris
Cuomo is jacked as [ __ ] and let me tell
you something if coronavirus can get him
we're all [ __ ] cuz that dude he looks
like you benchpress his [ __ ] Anthony
Cuomo how insecure is Trump about
Anthony Cuomo too when he [ __ ] said
the thing about how Andrew Andrew Cuomo
whoops Andrew Cuomo
when I say Anthony Cuomo is cuz he I'd
like to make people who look Italian so
much more Italian what [ __ ] Anthony
quo meanie and Andrew Cuomo Prentiss
there's a third brother
so anyway Trump was like gave it's just
so crazy that Trump gave Florida
everything they needed and not New York
everything they needed and blamed New
York for not be for for for asking for
too much and not using the ventilators
that they already have that's so crazy
to be like you don't need more
ventilators you're not using the one get
that people on the [ __ ] make people
die more I'll give them the Florida
because they need them because they're
all
at st. John's [ __ ] each other and
sucking anyway I don't need no [ __ ]
hook on this beat everybody's asking me
to talk about Tiger King and it's all
good it's all good
Tiger King is pretty wild I don't even
really know what to say about it Tiger
King is one of those things that speak
for itself let me actually do these ads
first and and then I can do Adam and Eve
calm you guys I love it I love being sex
positive I love it you know I do Adam
and Eve says the best part of staying at
home is playing at home look I'm not
trying to be dirty but if you're gonna
be at home and you have to be at home
for weeks on end there's only so many
things you could do you watch TV you
could eat dinners with your family you
could do exercising but you could also
bust a lot take advantage of the
downtime and choose almost any one item
at 50% off when you go to Adam and Eve
when you do you'll also get 10 free
boredom busting gifts including 6 spicy
movies Boston a three piece bonus kit
busting and best of all free shipping
delivered discreetly right to your door
that's awesome it doesn't necessarily
make me bust that it's discreet but also
it could because it's like a secret and
yeah bus quicker when [ __ ] is a secret
remember when you go there use the offer
code Congrats
that's Congrats at checkout hey Andy
Adam and Eve has thousands of products
to make you glad you are staying at home
if you're gonna be at home for a long
time you might as well be busting sex
toys make being at home so enjoyable
hell even shopping from home is more
enjoyable when you're shopping sex toys
ain't that right go to Adam and Eve calm
and use that offer code Congrats that's
Adam and Eve calm and use the offer code
congrats and you know if you want to be
ready for the log cabin you got to get
used to busting if you've got a a person
your quarantine with your wife or your
girlfriend or your husband or whatever
it is Adam
komm is where it's at speaking of which
manscaped if you're listening to this
podcast stuck inside your house with
your significant other other i want you
to play pay close attention today's
sponsor manscape can help you out and
make the most of your time together
manscaped promotes clean hygiene when it
comes to shaving your balls it's time to
quarantine manscaped and chill you are
probably spending more time than ever
with your significant other right now
and let me tell you if you don't keep
clean down there your partner will
notice ok you know my [ __ ] looks like
sometimes who's that muppet beakers hair
but not with not with manscape i keep it
nice and I start looking presidential
eye you want your you want your
downstairs area to look presidential you
want it to look like weaker manscaped I
hope it look like the presidential area
may escape this forever changing the
grooming game with a perfect package 3.0
essentials kit I'll tell you also it
really does a good job it doesn't Nick
my nuts the 3-point no the perfect
package 3.0 kit comes with the new and
improved lawn mower 3.0 water proof
cordless body trimmer and a ton of other
liquid formulations to round out your
manscaping routine it's really great
when you purchase the new perfect
package three-point okay at mass get
calm you get the biggest bang for your
buck subscribers get a new replacement
blade for refill for your lawn mower
trimmer delivered to your door every
three months making sure your trimmer
always stays fresh and clean for a
limited time subscribers get not one but
two free gifts the shed travel bag $39
value add and the patented
high-performing anti chafing manscaped
boxer briefs get 20% off and free
shipping with the code babies at
manscape com that's 20% off with the
free shipping and manscape at manscape
calm and use code babies don't forget
that your partner your body and your
balls will thank you um so anyway a
watched Tiger King and it was about Theo
cuz that guy if I had to pick any friend
that it looks like it's Theo
people are like oh [ __ ] David Spade
played him in [ __ ] what do you call
it Joe
dirt and I'm just like no Theo Vaughn is
him though period and so I saw Tiger
King and everyone on Tiger King I have a
question for you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you're
morons everyone every single [ __ ]
person on Tiger King is a goddamn [ __ ]
and yeah it's funny and now yeah watch
the show
and can you believe it and at
arms-length you're like wow that's
amazing that life but those people that
are living that life they're in this
world you could bump into them and
that's a problem because those people
are [ __ ] idiots everyone right down
to it from [ __ ] the tiger King to the
other dude who wore the bandanna and the
Hat by the way where one headpiece
especially if you're white why does
everyone in the movie two in the shows
they all like look like they would jerk
off outside of affliction just staring
in the [ __ ] front store storefront
just jerking off at the new affliction
designs RQ oh I can't wait till I come
out with the affliction is the worst
[ __ ] clothing of all time by the way
it's so bad why does it why do you need
to have tattoos on your [ __ ] shirt
why can't you just have them on your
body everything that affliction ever
made it looks like it was a tattoo put
on a shirt of like my tattoo is like
it'll be like an eagle on fire with the
word affliction over it or some [ __ ]
dragon god that guy how about the guy
who was like the big potato with the
long hair that was just like why do i
how come everybody why does everybody
who have tigers want to [ __ ] as many
people around them well what is that
about everyone there was like well I
have I roll around with that [ __ ] big
potato guy that his beard was his goatee
was white and he had the long hair and
he he told the documentary crew cut once
he was like and that's how it is cut I
think we got it that long potato [ __ ]
guy he just was like
even though he goes like well I have
five girls that just follow me around
why do they all why just be a cult
leader well what's with the Tigers these
guys are like step one get Tigers step
two
[ __ ] all the girls no except for the
tiger King guy was just like making
straight dudes fuck'em trying to pretend
like they did you married two straight
dudes and [ __ ] them and [ __ ] and they
were just like I'm not gay I don't know
I just [ __ ] how how [ __ ] dumb do
you have to be to let a guy if you're
not gay make you be like [ __ ] it I'll
marry him and just [ __ ] him for a bunch
of years when the guy showed up when his
husband his first husband showed up and
they did the [ __ ] floating ahead of
him just interviewing him he had no
[ __ ] shirt on the directors must have
been like a pig and [ __ ] when that
happened if that happened to me I would
have been like okay let's get the guy
and he was like all right where you want
to go and I'll be like oh cool you want
to get dressed maybe like what do you
mean I'll be like oh no nevermind oh sit
down
go ahead shirt off that's fine hair all
over his body I feel kind of bad for
some of these guys like that guy I felt
kind of bad for but just how stupid do
you have to be to be not gay but marry a
guy and let him [ __ ] you for nine years
how dumb is that dude I mean I'm
straight what would have to go down for
me to [ __ ] and let a guy rail me for
nine years what cut would have to go
down I'd have to be in prison I said a
long time ago
people are like oh how long you know
sometimes you talk to your friends how
long would it take for you to start
[ __ ] guys what would it take if you
were in what would it take three will
you take me to be in prison for eight
days eight [ __ ] days that's it that's
how long a week goes by and I'm like I I
guess I gotta [ __ ] him I gotta I gotta
[ __ ] guys what this was a deal for how
long how long to would I have to be in
jail for like if I was gonna get out in
a year I could public all year without
doing it but if I was gonna be in jail
for three years eight days eight days it
would take for me to [ __ ] guys and then
to
years later I get out and they be like
what happened I'd be like eight days
lasted [ __ ] a bunch of guys now let's
go get these chicks that's how it would
be for me but to just straight-up be
like okay I'll marry a guy cuz of his
Tigers even though I'm straight and let
him [ __ ] me for nine years just insane I
thought it's so weird that these guys
just want to get these Tigers in and
then the guy at the end with the
affliction shirt and the two hats was
just like well I got her pregnant and
we're gonna get a nanny and guess what
and shows you the picture of the nanny
and the nanny looks like a [ __ ] girl
that will be on tick-tock and you're
just like what she's just like he's like
I got to pick the nanny he's just gonna
[ __ ] the nanny while his girls pregnant
and then he's a we're gonna pop this
baby out of her and then then we're
gonna get her in the gym the Texas City
and our said hey a nurse said hey sir
toxic masculinity and I don't even
believe in that dumb [ __ ] anytime a guy
coughed somebody's like that's toxic
masculinity nowadays you know what thank
God for the [ __ ] coronavirus at least
people aren't getting [ __ ] canceled
anymore for [ __ ] for just like
farting I swear to god dude I'm not even
gonna mention it but one of my buddies
got [ __ ] outed for some [ __ ] and then
the coronavirus happened and everyone
forgot about that that dudes like hell
yeah
he's like a bunch of tens of thousands
of people died that's fine but at least
I get to [ __ ] do a deal now the Texas
Italian or Saturday and or Saturday
unbelievable dude that [ __ ] made me
laugh do it about the tiger king when he
was just like gonna get the best part
about tiger king though and if you
[ __ ] tell me this is wrong go [ __ ]
yourself we don't get along the best
thing in tiger King first of all the
second best thing in tiger King was when
he was at the funeral when his when is
when is one of his husbands died and he
started talking about how the dead guy
would put his balls in his face whenever
he needed and that's why he loved them
and [ __ ] that was
second best but the best part was when
he was like okay now hit it and then
started singing his terrible country
music I mean imagine your friend dies
imagine your lover dies and you're like
man missed him so much I miss him so
much he was so great
any time I was down he'd put him he'd
put his balls in my face hit it it's not
unusual to be mad at anyone let it in
and there yeah man I just got to tell
you we all miss him
and it sucks he was a real stand-up guy
meaning he'd stand up and put his balls
over my eyes whenever I wanted head it's
not unusual to be god I miss my wife
used to [ __ ] her gash man I can't
believe my wife is gone it's so sad if
everything about it was when she used to
kiss my [ __ ] I hated oh [ __ ] favorite
thing about it was when she used to pee
on me it's not unusual to be I keep
forgetting I'm not in love anymore
wow I'm losing my mind nobody's in this
room dude that's the best part of tiger
King man ah man miss my husband he used
to [ __ ] my body here we go one and a-two
and a-three it's not unusual dude when
people get mad at me for milk and jokes
go [ __ ] yourself I'll do it I'll do this
whole episode to the end I'll do
different [ __ ] things I used to love
when he used to [ __ ] blast in my
mouth hate it it's that our new jamala
my favorite is one he used to [ __ ] me
a-one and a-two and a-three
I keep forgetting it's not in love
anymore just [ __ ] I miss my husband
he used to suck my [ __ ]
found out a cons real name
do you guys know a cons real name did I
talk about this on the podcast I've made
so much fun of a con on my podcast for
some reason I made up that he was 4 feet
tall and because the Dothraki Lanza does
when he sings but his real name is Ali
Anu
Damali boga teammate Peru naka lululu
Barrera akin TM too many names that's
crazy dude and you can't cancel me for
being racist because the coronavirus le
na de Malabo go team a peru and knock
out lu lu lu bad era a con TM it's
hilarious that he chose [ __ ] a con
out of that you know it comes like the
most what would you like it to be but
what's wrong with team a or Peru or NACA
or Lou Lou Lou or Vdara a con wow dude
so Tiger king dude amazing it's good you
know if I had watched it though two
weeks after I watched it I would have
been like what's all the fuss about
that's the thing that sucks about this
every time the fork and someone said you
got to see this you got to see this you
got to see this you gotta see this er to
see this and then you [ __ ] watch it
you're like okay yeah it's good but why
is everybody flipping out about it but
if I had seen Tiger King on my own
without anybody [ __ ] telling me about
it what that would have been I would
have been like oh you got to [ __ ] see
this and I would have shouted it from
the rooftop Tiger king just sounds like
an Aquaman villain or some [ __ ] I guess
not Aquaman maybe what's his name black
panther
Black Panther and Tiger King um yeah so
it's what it is mine it's what it isn't
mine
well that's the other thing I wanted to
[ __ ] talk about - I um did I cross
out of it already I'm a dick I am a dick
dude gotta go back into my email yes
dude your along with me man let's just
chill let's chill we're doing this cuz
it's fine because the coronavirus is uh
hey dude Apple I don't want to keep
being told that there's updates on my
computers I'm not gonna [ __ ] do them
so stop going in the upper right-hand
corner and saying hey there's an update
available I don't give a [ __ ] dude stop
um so anyway I got more ads to do and
it's loading I do them fun I'm fun as
[ __ ] to it honey
we all shop online a lot especially
nowadays but did you know you can make
online shopping even better did you know
that because I didn't think you could
because you just sit in your PJs or
sometimes with no pants on on the couch
while you're watching the sweetest thing
with Thomas Jane and the other girl from
the mask Cameron Diaz anyway you know it
can make it better honey you can be
doing all that and you could be using
honey honey is the free online shopping
tool that saves you money online
honey automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your cart
which makes online shopping finally feel
as easy as it's supposed to be honey has
found over 18 million members over 2
billion dollars in savings did you hear
that how you do what are you doing not
one of these 918 million members get on
there did you know honey supports over
thirty thousand stores online including
Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy hmm have
you heard of those yeah and they're
adding more every day okay users love
honey that's why it has over a hundred
thousand five-star reviews on Google
Chrome on the google chrome store how it
works
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites Target Best Buy Sephora
Macy's eBay Etsy Walmart whatever well
you check out this little box drops down
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds for it to
scan for every promo code on the
internet and the prices drop did you
know that honey supports over three
hundred thirty thousand source online
Yaga did because I said that honey has
been a sponsor for a long time and the
most amazing how it just cycles through
the promo codes and just saves you money
so it doesn't no cost no nothing it
always feels good to see that it's very
cool not using honey is literally
passing up free money so why would you
do that it's free to use and installs in
just a few seconds plus it's backed by
PayPal so you know it's good honey get
it for free at join honey Comstock
Congrats that's join honey calm /
Congrats post mates when you need red
wine at 4 p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. and a
breakfast burrito at 8 a.m. or ibuprofen
at 10 a.m.
post made it doesn't matter what time
does matter what you need post places
your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever kind of delivery
service all year round I use it all the
time and it's great to do it during
times like these anything you're craving
post mates can deliver they're the
largest on-demand network in the US and
offer delivery with all from all the
restaurants grocery and convenience
stores and traditional retailers you
could possibly want or need it's 24
hours a day 365 days a year if the
stores open post plates is open it'll
bring you what you need within the hour
no more trips to the store you don't
want to go out now do you so you don't
even know if they even know where the
store is you just look on the app and it
tells you what tells you what to get
that's close by and you just pick it
download the app for iOS or Android for
free it's so easy browse local
restaurants for a limited time post
mates is giving our listeners $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use congrats that's
the code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery
credit for your first seven days when
you download the postmates sap anything
you need anytime you need it post made
it
download post mates and save with code
Congrats what's worse the corona virus
or Apple Apple TV remote straight-up
Apple TV needs to figure out it's
[ __ ] remote and this is the thing if
I've been doing my podcast for three and
a half years for anything it's all been
to culminate in this moment which is
telling you how [ __ ] bad the goddamn
Apple the TV remote sucks what's the
deal Apple remote TV are you too
sensitive or are you not sensitive
enough because when I'm sitting on the
couch and I roll over a little bit and
my shirt touches it and then all of a
sudden I'm watching [ __ ] Breaking Bad
when I was watching you know ozark I
thought it's supposed to work for my
[ __ ] touch or the heat or whatever
then my shirt rolls on and all of a
sudden I'm watching episode 9 season 2
of Breaking Bad it's like and then when
I go to [ __ ] hit it how about when
you go to hit back when you want to go
back 10 seconds and it pauses instead
nah now that pisses me off
I'd rather get [ __ ] dude that dry is
there a way to go back for 10 seconds or
not cuz when I hit it it works one time
in the one I'll go back again 10 seconds
I pause it and then I gotta drag it back
and when I go to [ __ ] drag it back it
goes too far and then I go forward a
little bit and then I'm right back to
where I was and that's not where I
wanted to be I wanted to be back [ __ ]
20 seconds that's what I wanted to be so
why can't I [ __ ] hit the back 20
seconds I can where can't hit the back
twice these are real issues dude they
need to do an NP are able to have a
thought about that there's so much spit
all over my computer and I don't give a
[ __ ]
Apple TV remote figure your [ __ ] out
you're not sleek you're not cool if you
don't work period make it work have real
buttons on the [ __ ]
I was blackberry for so hard until I got
the iPhone because I had to get the
iPhone because the BlackBerry didn't
have the Instagram I was blackberry so
hard dude I wanted to click those
buttons I want to hear that button click
click call me old school call me 40 I
don't give a [ __ ] blackberry was the
[ __ ] click click click I was European
until 2016 using that [ __ ] blackberry
and it wasn't that far but you know what
I'm trying to say I'm exaggerating but
the iPhone I finally had to get it
because Instagram was the [ __ ] so I got
I phone and then finally I learned how
to do the [ __ ] thing without the
buttons but still I love buttons man I'm
European through and through I was
European till I was like 33 with the
[ __ ] blackberry you saw European
still there's some Europeans out there
right now still with the BlackBerry well
you know it just it still works back you
know it still works for us people in
Dubai still using that blackberry like
haha i phones no those are for peasants
people were just too many clothes
pulling out their [ __ ] blackberries I
made fun of a guy on Twitter like six
days ago and I was just in 2d I'm sure
he's a nice guy looks like a nice guy
made fun of him he said something about
he did a thing on on Twitter he wrote
about it was a long time ago let me find
it but watch my special April 14th no
pain on Netflix I wrote it just in hoops
in McElroy he wrote he wrote on March
21st hey I'm not trying to censor
anybody but you before you casually joke
about the apocalypse please consider
that's a pretty tough anxiety trigger
for a lot of folks look I don't know who
this guy is it doesn't matter I'm
probably out of the loop the guys
probably famous as [ __ ] good on him he's
probably very successful and I don't
know who anybody is and then I write ah
the sentence went on too long huh it
should stop after the word anybody all
good though meaning hey I'm not trying
to censor anybody is the thing to say
and I was just [ __ ] around
I'm sure the guy's a nice guy I'm sure
if I met him I'd get along with him and
I [ __ ] write this [ __ ] and people are
just like most people are like oh yeah
so yeah II shouldn't say that [ __ ] him
and it's like no not [ __ ] him do
I'm lightly just playing with the guy
and then somebody writes this saying it
crisps which is so annoying when
somebody says this ain't it justin is
one of the nicest most caring and
funniest people in the world please
don't stick your fans on him for no
reason every time you just scared as
[ __ ] about internet whatever and I wrote
I'm sure he's a great guy I'm messing
around like I always am I'm sure Jesse
McCord can take it but yeah my fans
could take it too fun so far sometimes I
forgot about that she writes you have no
idea how much I appreciate your kind
response fans can go overboard and
defending the people in love and it's
really mature of you to listen so it's
all good I hope
I don't care if it's all good who who
are you I hope you listen to Justin
stuff because he and his brothers have
changed a lot of light show that her
that's cool I'll listen and I probably
will at some point but like oh stop
talking to me Kayla you know alright I'm
playing with the guy I'm sure the guy
saw my thing and was like ah whatever if
he was upset I didn't mean to upset him
I was just playing and then somebody are
you're sick in your mic if you see my
tweet and I'm making fun of somebody and
then you take it too far and you start
DM and someone say [ __ ] you this that
bro
you're a loser okay fan of mine or not
like just this is Twitter dude like you
can make fun of people all day long but
it doesn't matter I'm in front of this
guy the guy maybe reads that on his
podcast makes fun of me it's all good I
don't give a [ __ ] god somebody I like
here's the other thing too I block
everybody on my Instagram if somebody
says something negative or somewhat
negative to me on my Instagram that's it
that's your ass see ya it's a privilege
following someone on Instagram is a
privilege it's not a right if you say
something negative and the person blocks
you
that's that ass but you understand that
because you don't know the guy somebody
thinks it's funny to comment on
my Instagram or somebody's Instagram
[ __ ] you and they think that's a joke if
somebody came up to you on the street
and said [ __ ] you how the [ __ ] you think
that would react punch in the face the
equivalent of that is blocking someone
in online I'll just block something I
don't give a [ __ ] I go like this I block
I don't want anything negative period
[ __ ] the number one thing somebody says
after that is I mean somebody [ __ ] I
don't know how they found it but
somebody wrote me last two day few days
ago I guess he came across this guy's
tweet I can't wait to hear this story he
writes and this guy tweeted Krista Lea
blocks when offended but gets mad when
people are offended modern-day comedians
everybody big yikes I get mad when
people are offended at jokes how do you
not understand the difference it's
stupid of you to be offended at a joke
it's not stupid of you to be offended
when somebody is talking [ __ ] that you
don't know so you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's all good and then I love how he was
like modern-day comedians like this guy
he's in his 20s like he's some [ __ ]
purist well I wish we could go harken
back to the days of when George Carlin
was coming up when nobody this and that
and you could have said it and the
[ __ ] thing in the I wish we could go
back to the days of Kinison when he is -
got him mother
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude and he had a
Don Quixote beard and [ __ ] like who you
don't matter dude neither do i what are
you [ __ ] saying that's some peep
do to think that they might all he
blocked me I don't even think about it
my buddy said are you what's this story
all about he texted me the screenshot I
said dude I have no clue I block anybody
who says anything negative
uh who are you who who I don't run I
forgot it's so funny - sometimes people
will be like ah well I got you I pissed
you off and it's like yeah I will never
ever think about this interaction ever
again after two minutes pass and you'll
never forget that this happened right
like take the mic like you you know if
you interact with a you know I'm a
[ __ ] d-list celebrity but if you
interact with somebody who's got a large
following and you have don't have a
large following you'd remember that
happens to me all [ __ ] day I don't
remember these from the [ __ ] so go
ahead congratulations you got blocked
yeah your life's great whatever anyway
listen to that hoops guy he seems like
he's positive and he's probably good and
he's got a nice face but there was a
[ __ ] thing on Instagram where they
were like doing a it was quarantine NYC
and they were doing a an Instagram oh
god it's it's so [ __ ] embarrassing
see if I could find it the page isn't
available why's it say that was just
available it was its quarantine NYC and
it was supposed to be this this thing
about how it was an online rave or
something or a DJ set that somebody was
doing and it was like 10 bucks to
[ __ ] be a part of this all you got to
do is like sign in and you can get a
table and then like what a DJ plays on a
on on an Instagram and you're at home
sad you're at home
there you're not there I get the [ __ ]
iTunes just listen to it wow that's
amazing
they were like first 100 people 10 bucks
can only let 100 people in or some [ __ ]
no you can let as many people in you're
not letting anyone in anywhere what a
racket and then people are like oh you
should go on do a set live on insta go
to a set do a comedy set no dude that
would be so bad and if you don't know
that would be bad
that's crazy that's just so crazy can
you do an Instagram can you do a lot
some kind of live pop you know stand-up
set yeah at the club's when this is all
over that's when I can do it at the
club's when this is all over because if
I were to do it imagine if I did I have
25 minutes of new material imagine if I
just blew it on Instagram life making no
money and also getting no laughs people
would just be like where's the part to
laugh
it's not it's not available he just sent
it again to click on this one it's not
available I don't know why it's not
working I was thinking about his story
when I was a kid this was this [ __ ] this
is how you know I'm down dude I'm down
for my [ __ ] homies and this is
how you know I'm down for my homies is
because when I was boy I must have been
in fifth grade a kid came in to class
and it was a new student we had a new
student when I was in fifth grade his
name was Thomas that's all I remember I
remember his last name didn't call
himself Tom that [ __ ] name was
Thomas and he was the kind of guy who
looked like he should be graduating
college you know how sometimes the kid
is just like there's a kid in your
school in your class and you're in fifth
grade and he just looks like one of the
kids dads
he was wiry and tall it was his black
dude nice look and you know Thomas me I
always been trending the new people
because I wanted to learn all about him
because let's face it the everyday
[ __ ] was mundane as [ __ ] so started
talking to Thomas Thomas turns out had
so many [ __ ] penthouses and Playboy's
and [ __ ] and I didn't know why when I
was fit when I was in fifth grade I
thought ah this guy must just have a
[ __ ] up parents right because how does
he had access to this [ __ ] but he'd come
and he'd bring the [ __ ] pieces of the
pieces of paper from penthouse and it
was the first time ever saw like you
know [ __ ] and I seen tits before but
like I saw girls like finger in
themselves and stuff I'll never get a
Disney movie and so I saw him doing that
or I saw him giving out the things and
and and he was giving he gave one to me
and I was like wow and I remember
feeling like wow this looks weird but I
like it but also it's weird because you
know those girls they didn't look
natural they had really big boobs
and the pussy's look like fried
butterflies and their hair was all
teased out like I never seen girls like
that you know and this was even in New
Jersey when the girls hairs in the 80s
were not so teachers and [ __ ] mm-hmm
anyway uh I was like whoa man and he was
like yeah he's like I got more where
that came from and I was like really and
he was like you want me to bring him and
I was like you up he's like all you got
to do is bring my schnitz give me your
snacks tomorrow I was like damn cool
okay so the next day I was like hey Dad
can I get extra potato skins in my thing
we had the little plain or peanut potato
skins things that we used to have I
usually you don't know if they still
[ __ ] exist anymore and and and I came
and he gave me more [ __ ] more more
nudes and I would and I would uh and I
would give on petitions and it would go
down like a [ __ ] drug deal dude
I just give it the I just slide over the
[ __ ] things I would slide the [ __ ]
over there and he would give me the [ __ ]
and this show would be you know what I
mean and camp later we'll get copyright
infringement probably already got [ __ ]
with it but anyway I would be sending I
would give him the [ __ ] and he would
give me the [ __ ] and then I go into the
bathroom and that opened up the
magazines and I'd see it and I would see
new [ __ ] and new tits and it was
awesome dude and this is the time where
I realized I guess I'm straight didn't
know about gay but you know if I had I
would have been like hey I guess I'm
straight
so really liked it and when I got home I
don't want to keep in the house you know
like when I watch Breaking Bad and when
Walter White is putting the money in the
air vent I'm like bro I would have found
that in two seconds well luck luckily
outside of my back yard down a little
bit there was a park it was called yeah
Nicole book Park and I went with my
friend Matt Ravenna and we took these
photos of these girls [ __ ] and tits
and we went way back to the other end of
the park and we would bury them we would
bury these pictures of tits and [ __ ]
in baseball card collector holder things
okay and we bury them in a can
that you would stack baseball cards in
and we put something over it so we could
always go back to you in a car broke
park and get into that [ __ ] can and
look at those tits and we didn't we
wouldn't get we have I don't know if we
got the owners back then you know but we
were just like we would just open it up
like it was treasure it felt cool dude
and sometimes if I go over there just
rolling on my dough Lo and [ __ ] go
look at four can't it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
put him back in the thing and go back
and eat dinner with my family and nobody
knew [ __ ] do it and it was it was dope
as [ __ ] dude I felt good and I felt
sneaky I felt like you know like I had
some [ __ ] going on and we this lasted
for about a week or two and my dad said
mm-hmm one day hey Chris come into my
office and I said okay which was weird
he never [ __ ] did that I went into
his office and he says hey is there a
kid at school that's giving you nudes
like pictures of naked women and I said
yeah that's the kind of guy I am
when I'm caught I tell you what's up
that's it
I let the cards fall as they may and he
says okay what are the pictures of and I
explained [ __ ] and tits and stuff
although I didn't say it like that when
I was in fifth grade I just naked women
and he said okay
he said I want to know what these
pictures are can you show me and I said
okay
so I went to [ __ ] Yannick our Brook
Park and rolling a modelo grab the
[ __ ] things went back up to the dad's
office [ __ ] threw the pictures up on
the thing and I said hey they're up
there like this and he saw him and he
said okay cool that's all and I said
really am I in trouble and he said no
and I said okay
he said well you shouldn't be doing that
stuff at school or whatever and I said
okay cool and then uh I felt weird I
left the room didn't know how he knew it
and then a few days later he said to me
you know I said how did you find out
about that [ __ ] and he said you know I
found out another dude who lived on the
opposite end of Yan 2-car book Park who
was just a [ __ ] [ __ ] rat [ __ ] you know
what I mean a [ __ ] rat [ __ ] like a piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] like his face was he was
one of those kids who had the faces that
were like it was like pink in weird
areas you know I'm talking about like
you know he was younger than me by the
way I rat-fucked younger than me in like
fourth or third grade and he had the
pink like that [ __ ] eczema oh I don't
really know what the [ __ ] it is it's not
eczema but it's just like it's like hi-c
it's like leftover hi-c on his [ __ ]
face just a dirt [ __ ] rat [ __ ] and he
said I got a doorbell he knocked on my
he hit the doorbell and it was him the
kid never [ __ ] came over and he said
hey mr. D'Elia he said yeah and he said
I want you to know that Chris and Matt
trevenna n-- are hiding dirty pictures
outside the back of yenicall park near
my house and my dad said oh yeah and he
said yeah and then my dad said he looked
at this rat [ __ ] and said so and the rat
[ __ ] said oh I just thought you should
know that you know cuz they're naked and
my dad said again so what he said okay
and he turned around and my dad said do
you know why I said that that way I said
why he said because he was trying to get
you in trouble and I didn't want to let
him have the satisfaction of it so I
acted like it wasn't a big deal so he
felt stupid
and I learned that then and that's how I
know now to be down as [ __ ] to your
family
that one [ __ ] thing that happened
definitely stuck with me forever and
that rat [ __ ] [ __ ] fourth grader die
slow [ __ ] my dad taught me a
goddamn lesson and then I said well
why'd you want to see the pics he said
well honestly the only reason why the
pigs want to make sure they were okay
and just have naked women and they
weren't doing like weird stuff with
animals or some [ __ ] I was like oh yeah
that makes sense
goddamn I love my dad that's so dope I
can't wait to be on my kids side I mean
I am now but like I can't wait for that
[ __ ] to happen and some [ __ ] to go down
and for me to look at some other kid
that's from a rat [ __ ] out of my rat
[ __ ] my son and have him be like and
I'ma be like so man I learned I learned
that day that was cool and also [ __ ]
turns out of like two titties and
[ __ ] - so um hmm anyway I guess
that's it - I forgot about that story
and I wanted to tell you on the podcast
because I thought it was cool but you
got to be down as [ __ ] to your family
man you got to be down as [ __ ] thanks
guys
look it's a little weird doing this
podcast all alone I got to be honest I'm
trying to do my my [ __ ] right and be
good by everyone and not be out and stay
in my house alone doing this podcast and
not have one fire or Ivan get rid of
over here so we're not coughing on each
other who knows but I'm doing the social
distancing and I'm taking it seriously
and you should too men and if you live
in Florida and if you're going to beat
the beaches and [ __ ] you're you're a
straight-up piece of [ __ ] you're like a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] just stay in for a
little bit man even if it's for a few
months just stay and man people are
dying and you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you don't you really are and I mean that
[ __ ] I know a lot of this stuff is jokes
and all that and I barely mean anything
but you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] if
you're going out to social gatherings
men you really are so anyway you could
text me at eight one eight two three
nine seventy eighty seven and makes
you put my Netflix thing in your queue
you can do that because it was my
birthday the other day so if you know
it's my birthday I'm asking you to put
the Netflix thing in your queue and
watch it when it comes out on April 14th
that's called no paint Chris D'Elia
don't know when all my stand-up dates
are gonna be happening but it'll be
happening thank you guys for listening
and you guys are the [ __ ]
[Music]